well I'm nearing the end of my second
week today was not a tremendously
eventful day there's no shots from my
iPhone but there will be tomorrow today
I was pretty busy played hockey in the
morning had to work in the side this
afternoon in the office got in about I
would say an hour of reading and
probably 3040 minutes of listening plus
I had thirty minutes of conversation
with one of our tutors at Lincoln I
actually recorded it on on my software
that I have but and I have it set for
split screen but it only showed my tutor
didn't show me so I decided not to to
share it I'm gonna try to get that
recording software working so that on
subsequent discussions you can see me
struggling with my Korean I'm gonna try
to get maybe two three hours a week of
talking in with our tutors if I can line
up enough people to speak to me in
Korean
my experience with Romanian was that if
I do two to three hours a week of
talking that combined with my intensive
input activities that that's enough to
really to progress I did feel that I
spoke much better than the last time I
feel that I'm understanding what I'm
reading in the newspaper better I still
have a lot of trouble understanding but
I know from experience that I just have
to continue to chip away at it just
continue listening and reading continue
speaking more and gradually the brain is
gonna get used to it and so really
that's all I have to report today I
discovered there's a thing here called
the Korean cultural center so I phoned
them I left a message for the director
I might go snoop around and see who I
can meet so that I can also generate
some more face-to-face contact here in
Vancouver I'm nearing the end of my
second week 90 days that's a total of 13
weeks so I hopefully I'm moving fast
enough so that by the end of the 90 days
I'll have made meaningful progress
really understand what people say and
really be able to express
myself talk to you later